[Musica]
cinque secondi tempo che sono uscito
dalle quinte dato un colpo di d'occhio
così per mettere a fuoco due milioni e
mezzo di messaggi sul whatsapp più di
4.000 foto postate dato più
significativo di questo tsunami
didattiche è andato sulla rete in questo
pochissimo lasso di tempo sono i soldi
che sono andati in fumo o per mitigare o
per in qualche modo qualcuno che voleva
impossessarsi dei nostri valori
economici e poi oltre 200 mila persone
di cui probabilmente a qualcuno in
questa sala
nonostante i telefoni sono stati spenti
in questo momento è stato sotto un
potenziale attacco cibernetico e quindi
parlerò di cybersecurity l'uomo e la
sicurezza sono andati di pari passo
l'uomo della preistoria
io dico era locale quindi la sua
comunicazione poteva essere di tipo
locale
un gesto un suono un po di voce però
intercettazioni e quel caso era molto
limitata
e poi c'è stata una grande evoluzione
quindi un embrace medi una grande
tecnologia ha imparato a scrivere allora
dai muri la portata su un pezzo di carta
nel momento in cui ha portato la
scrittura su un pezzo di carta ha fatto
in modo tale che questa scrittura
potesse essere in qualche modo
interpretata da qualchedun altro da un
altro da un terzo e allora sono andati
via giù vari codici per per mistificare
la scrittura crittografie varie famoso
il codice enigma che ha in qualche modo
anche contributo a risolvere un evento
un evento bellico e poi la da remoto
siamo passati a una comunicazione
globale e quando i globali ci siamo
anche seduti siamo comodi sul nostro
poltrona ma andiamo messaggi
tranquillamente direi in modo
completamente disinvolto un po di anni
fa 80 90 anni fa per per poter
comunicare per fare una telefonata oggi
la chiamiamo una chiamata vocale e
bisognava andare al centro
ecco perché si amano centrali bisognava
al centro e c'erano le
le signorine che collegavano con un cavo
e lì era proprio il massimo dell
insicurezza totale c'era da man in the
middle
perché sapeva chi stava chiamando sapeva
chi volevamo chiamare e volendo poteva
anche ascoltare quello che si stavano
dicendo
e questo oggi non sarebbe possibile che
una persona ascolta se non per questioni
legali o regolatori e ascolta quello che
stiamo dicendo il progresso ha portato
poi questo oggetto è che che immagino
questa platea tutti conoscano
però io sono porto nelle scuole
elementari o nelle scuole medie
la prima cosa che mi dicono è una
calcolatrice perché vedono i numeri e
sapete una cosa che mi chiedono più
spesso e non può essere un telefono
perché dove è che si accende e questa
questa mi fa riflettere questa cosa mi
fa riflettere mi impressiona poi non c'è
il display quindi proprio non puoi
venirci a dire che un telefono
eppure questo era il primo il primo
oggetto di scatto alla risposta e aveva
una certa differenza scatto per la
risposta altro che palestre squillava il
telefono via scatto per rispondere chi 6
chivu e quindi la privacy zero perché
chiaramente fin tanto che era la
famiglia ancora ancora ma se era una
comunità un bar si sapeva e ti stanno
chiamando quindi privacy assolutamente
compromessa e su questo su questo
oggetto siamo stati per tanto tempo per
poi arrivare
diciamo con un salto enorme ai giorni
nostri forse non tutti sanno non tutti
sanno che abbiamo in questo modo e parlo
solo di telefonia mobile
attenzione abbiamo più sim che esse
domani 8 miliardi di sim allora allora
qui facciamo due conti si vaga qualcuno
di voi c'è il tablet il telefonino un
paio e mai neonati no non ancora
non ancora anche se qualche pannolino
cela la sigma per controllare l'umidità
così la madre lo controlla sul
telefonino però in questo momento molte
delle sim
molte delle sim sono nelle macchine e
allora quella comunicazione che era
locale e poi remota adesso è diventata
globale e anche
involontaria noi siamo sotto una rete di
comunicazione che è del tutto spesso e
volentieri involontaria quindi siamo nel
mondo nell'inter delle cose fantastico
ci lavoro e credo che sia una cosa
meravigliosa
l'internet delle cose di cui noi a
questo punto siamo una cosa possiamo un
essere umano è lì che dobbiamo capire
per quanto mi riguarda dobbiamo capire
il meccanismo cosa c'è dietro
dietro c'è una quella che in inglese
chiameremo la mauti stakeholder approcci
quindi c'è un insieme di cose ci sono i
governi che devono legiferare affinché
chi voglia inserire una rete di
comunicazioni in un paese così come
magari salvaguardiamo i confini dello
stesso paese vengono salvaguardati anche
i meccanismi di implementare una rete di
telecomunicazione e poi ci sono gli enti
regolatori ci sono i centri di ricerca
ci sono le università ci sono gli
ingegneri informatici che devono
studiare quali sono i meccanismi per
interconnettere le varie cose e poi ci
sono gli operatori di settore quelli
delle infrastrutture agli over the top
che sono tenuti costretti a mettere
dentro tutti gli elementi che servono
per intercettare o per mettere dei
firewall basta
no non basta non può bastare perché
l'elemento che fa parte e che deve
ritornare al centro siamo esattamente
noi siamo le persone ora è un po che
siete seduti giusto no quindi allora
immagino che tutti abbiate un telefono
non se faccio questa domanda in altri
paesi del centro dell'africa o in india
non tutti hanno il telefonino immagine
qui ce l'hanno
mi fate la cortesia il braccio destro
alzato per chi aveva il positioning
acceso del telefonino prima diventerà il
teatro non abbiate timore bene braccio
sinistro perché ha postato una foto
prima di entrare eccoli agitate un po le
mani così vi vedo 70 per cento bene in
questo momento chi voleva sapere che non
stavate a casa dove avete lasciato il
vostro motivi della vostra auto
questo lo sa perché magari è stato
dietro il vostro account come vuoi per
un phishing e voi non ve ne siete
accorti perché siete entrati in qualche
sito avete cliccato un'icona dove c'era
un bel catena chino non protetta e in
questo momento il vostro telefono o il
vostro tablet ha effettivamente un
phishing che sta dicendo le informazioni
che voi avete postato e allora le vostre
informazioni vostro profilo le vostre le
vostre foto
i vostri amici i vostri viaggi allora le
grandi aziende guardano su facebook
prima di fare un colloquio lo voglio
dire perché capita
e allora è direttamente pubblico
e allora se facciamo se stiamo
qualificandoci per il fashion blogger
può andare bene però magari altri
mestieri probabilmente sarebbe bene
guardare cosa abbiamo messo sul nostro
facebook
e allora dicevamo cosa c'è dietro le
reti dovete sapere che le reti per legge
devono essere intercettabili
quindi ci deve essere un procuratore che
può dire in qualche modo ad una rete io
devo poter intercettare un'informazione
devo poter entrare nei dati in una
persona in modo legale e quindi vuol
dire che ci sono dei meccanismi e quindi
ci si procurano dei firewall ultimati si
parla tantissimo non so quanti di voi
delle block chaining blog chain che sono
degli strumenti più o meno sicuri direi
molto più più sicuri perché
distribuiscono le formazioni la danno
per certa non è non è un solo luogo
quindi le reti hanno fanno la loro parte
ma anche noi
anche noi che non cambiamo la password
spesso e divisione da pasto e 1 2 3 e 4
stelle ce ne sono tante la più è la più
usata oppure la usiamo la stessa
password su tanti account oppure
insistentemente entriamo su reti che
palesemente non sono protette stiamo lì
a cercare esattamente quello che il
l'ingegnere informatico sopraffino non
quello sul cavallo bianco quello buono
quello che fa i firewall
ma quell altro quello sul cavallo nero e
altrimenti altrettanto bravo forse anche
più bravo che non fa altro che cercare
di entrare nei nostri dati cercando il
momento giusto per approfittare dei
nostri dati io spesso vado in viaggio
per lavoro per piacere
e alcune cose mi stimolano mi ispirano
mi danno grande grande grande i segnali
grandi messaggi
allora quando vedete una cosa del genere
un mercato
affollatissimo dove il meccanismo e la
naturalezza con la quale la gente si
comporta
all'arrivo di un treno all'interno di
questo mercato
sopra le cose e tutti quanti che si
organizzano per mettersi in sicurezza vi
posso assicurare che il video non
riporta attenzione a stare dietro la
linea gialla
no no c'è un meccanismo automatico di
autoregolamentazione l'uomo ha capito e
si è adattato per far sì che le cose
fossero fatte in sicurezza
ecco io io questo credo che bisogna
cominciare a pensare nel momento in cui
noi cominciamo a viaggiare sulla rete ad
utilizzare la rete
tutto normale tutto ritorna come prima
quando ero bambino saliva sull'autobus e
c'era un cartello che mi che mi ispirava
tanto non parlare al conducente sip chi
parla il conducente non si poteva
parlare e poi diceva massime posti a
sedere 55 anni massimo posti di entrata
55 45 55 bene saliamo era un cartello
era un informazione nei paesi del nord
ce n'è un altro quello che vedete che
c'è attenzione attenzione utenti sbadati
ci sono più incidenti per gente che si
confonde nella rete di altri di altri
tipologie di incidenti oggi oggi
semafori stanno sul pavimento non stanno
altezza altezza uomo stanno sul
pavimento perché la gente è abituato a
guardare in basso è piuttosto che
guardare in alto ecco stasera magari
insieme ne mettiamo un altro di cartello
in questo cartello che dice attenzione
stai andando su una rete non protetta
attenzione stai consegnando i dati stai
consegnato te stesso e stai consegnando
la tua cartella clinica si è consegnato
il tuo conto in banca
stai consegnato i dati biometrici del
tuo pacemaker ad un altro che se volesse
non solo li può leggere ma li può
intercettare devo modificare e questo
certamente quello che noi non vorremmo
ci parla del 5 gil 6 ci sarà un passo
avanti
ancor di più
nell'entrare intimamente nella rete
e allora magari come noi per viaggiare
ma driving licence oppure il brevetto
per per avere per poter pilotare un
aereo per andare in barca
io credo che sia arrivato il momento di
introdurre anche una sorta di licenza o
di brevetto per sapere come viaggiare
sulla rete sicura riconoscere quali sono
i meccanismi o quali sono le situazioni
che provocano tantissimo danno alle
persone alle cose e alle industrie e
questo è quello che io penso che sia
necessario in qualche modo entrare in
quella forma di cultura che mi dicevo
sulla sicurezza
i dati che noi abbiamo in possesso dei
nostri dati sono estremamente importanti
sono il petrolio del terzo millennio 45
dollari e il costo di un vostro profilo
quello comune quello normale vengono
scambiati i profili vengono scambiati
vengono venduti quindi immaginate quanto
business c'è dietro alla conoscenza dei
dati e se proprio qualche dubbio ce
l'avete chiedetelo a questo personaggio
che dietro alla grave risponde subito ve
lo sa dire esattamente quanto il valore
del vostro dato allora siccome ho visto
che qualcuno in sala ha cominciato a
togliere positioning abbandonato qualche
gruppo social battuto bene va tutto bene
l'importante è sapere che dietro la
sicurezza ci siamo noi piace
[Applauso]